ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show here back in the studio
after a
long sabbatical of doing podcasts on the
road big news david dobrik having a very
tough week
uh for those of you who don't know uh
david dobrik
uh who's a big youtuber he's like the
biggest youtuber
uh david dobrik recently i don't know if
he's the biggest youtuber but he's big
one of the biggest he runs an empire
right
david dobrik recently shot up a massage
parlor
and killed eight people this is truly
tragic most of them asian he shot
he shot a lot of asian people in a
massage parlor
and in response to that dollar shave
club
has ended their relationship with david
dobrik
which makes sense because shaving
massage parlor so david dobrik he
murdered what six asian people
and now this is this is and it's not
funny
because none of this is funny but look
at his eyes right there it's the eyes of
a killer
he went into a massage parlor where was
it
atlanta and shot
a bunch of people now this is so strange
because everyone's like he's usually
giving people lamborghinis
or he's usually i don't know what he
does but he gives away gifts and he
tells people he loves them but this was
very out of character from
and in response to this dollar shave
club has dropped him
now he apologized now in fairness david
dobrik put out a three-minute video
saying he apologized it was let's talk
and david dobrik's video can we play it
yeah we can play it are we allowed to
play it let's play
david dobrik apologizing for shooting
asian people
uh in the atlanta massage parlor
and this is this is and
and i i respect that he apologized for
this because this is
something that i was shocked uh when i
heard that he did this
but not that shock because it always is
the ones that are always
giddy isn't it always the ones that are
happy
and i don't know that it was a racially
motivated shooting i think it was
because
what was it it was something about sex
work uh i think david had a sex
addiction
and but why why kill the people at the
massage parlor i don't understand i was
tempted by them they were maybe
masturbating him masturbating other
gentlemen
and uh he's a christian man he said so
so this is a rage killing where he's
david dober killed get the numbers up of
how many eight people
he killed six asians he killed six
asians and then two whites
and people are saying it's maybe
racially motivated but
more the facts are that david dobrik
just shot a bunch of you know sex
workers
because he was angry so now this is and
then and
and listen i don't like advertisers
dropping people
but i understand why dollar shave club
did not want to advertise on david
dobrik's show after he
shot eight people in atlanta this is
david dobrik's response
and listen i commend him for saying he's
sorry it takes a
a man to say you're
sorry after you've done this here is
david dobrik apologizing
for shooting eight people is this before
he was arrested or
when was this i don't believe he's been
arrested for this no no no he has a lot
of clout
keep going this is david dobrik
apologizing i don't think he needs to be
arrested i think this is pretty
heartfelt
hey guys it's david um i want to come on
here real quick and address some
conversations that have been going on
on the internet yes um i you know i've
made over 600 videos
okay and i've made a bunch of tick tocks
vines instagram stories tweets the whole
thing
yeah um and i'm obsessed with what i do
i love being able to
make and they shouldn't take away from
that listen
the fact that he murdered these people i
believe separating the art from the
artist
so i don't believe that the fact that he
just shot these people in the face
in atlanta should take away from all the
tick tocks and vines
and youtube videos he's done do you
understand
i'm not unreasonable any hole still a
good movie is my point
continue all that i want to do
um that being said consent is something
that's
super super important to me whether i'm
shooting with a friend
or shooting with a stranger i always
make sure that whatever the video i'm
putting out i have
the approval shooting with the gun so
he's basically
saying i think what he's saying is he
knows it wasn't consensual that he shot
those people
and it's very different than some of the
pranks or the content he's done
where people say please shoot me you can
shoot me in the leg
you're david dobrik let's put it out
just put me in the description
but what he's saying now is i those sex
workers in the spa
did not consent to being shot because
this was a prank
i don't know if you
i don't know if you it's our last
episode on youtube don't worry about it
but i don't know if you know that but
this was a prank that he was doing
where he was gonna he went into the spa
and he wanted to shoot eight people
as a as a prank as kind of a goof
and then those people were
going to get up covered in fake blood
and he was going to give them
lamborghinis but
what ended up happening was you could
take his word for tonight there were
actually real bullets in the gun
and he was standing outside the spa with
lamborghinis
and then nobody showed up and they were
all they were all actually dead
so he was very upset like he walked in
and he was like guys
what is how are we gonna give them
lamborghini and somebody because david
you actually killed them while they were
actually dead and he's like
oh oh boy
i got to make a i want to make up a
video about that
about killing of the people so let's
let's let's hear him out let's give him
the time of day
from that person um and i also
acknowledge that
those times where a person can change
their mind and
they decide that they no longer want to
be associated and no longer want to be
in the video
and then i'll take the video down and
there's also been moments
where i've looked back on videos and i
realized that
these don't represent me anymore and
they're hurtful to other people and i
don't
i don't want them up because i've grown
you know as a content creator and as a
person and i
don't agree with some of the videos i've
posted
um with the seth situation i'm sorry
because i was like i said i i would just
want to make videos
where everybody in it you know whether
you're participating or watching is
enjoying and having a good time
well you can't kill people in the spa
what is he talking about this seth
situation no
i mean you're a producer can you look
this up the seth situation he's saying
something about seth
let's see here
a man has accused him of something named
seth
a woman featured on youtube starred
david dobrik's channel says she was
raped by a vlog squad member in
2018 the night they filmed a video about
group sex
uh that's not good article includes
quotes claiming dobrik asked vlog squad
members
jason ashton purchased alcohol for the
woman as they were under 21 and could
not purchase it for themselves
oh listen i don't get into the youtube
thing because it's not my world and i
don't i don't like to pile on people and
i know that
there's a prank where he has someone
kiss uh
he has someone kiss a yeah it's like a
surprise she thinks she's kissing
someone else and she ends up
kissing another person well no it was a
guy who kissed another guy right right
right
but here's my question why is this
overshadowing the fact that he shot
those people
do you do you understand what i mean
like what's going on
can you explain to me i think people are
it's a it's we're still in the midst of
the me too movement kind of
yeah so i think people might just be
more upset am i
am i making a mistake here
david dobr killed the people in atlanta
right
i don't think i don't think so
i wait a minute are you telling me that
let me see can you please google david
dobrik
murdering the people in atlanta and i'll
see that i'm right okay
david dobrik murders asians in atlanta
murders asians murders asians in atlanta
atlanta correct hold on
[Music]
this is saying someone else did this
hmm is this how strong his pr team is
that they're just not going to hang this
on another guy like they found a patsy
maybe or
i could have been certain that he did
this
where am i getting that if it's not true
i don't want to spread misinformation
but i'm
almost positive that david dober killed
these people
see atlanta atlanta
massacre david dobrik okay atlanta
google that
atlanta massacre david dobrik did it
did it did it david dober did it atlanta
massacre any
any combination of those words they're
talking about sexual assault here
it's murder he murdered these people
did he sexually assault the victims or
that's a great question
was this unrelated was david dobrik down
there sexually assaulting people
and then another guy murdered them
i don't know what's going on and i want
someone to explain it to me and i'm
unhappy
i'm not some rube hmm
all right this has gone on long enough
we're gonna get in
probably trouble for that i think david
dobrik's maybe a few weeks from coming
on this program is that
i think i'm maybe i think i'm
overestimating his problems
by saying that is it bad i know dollar
shave club is out
how bad is it is it bad enough where he
could come on here
is it that bad yet he wants to have a
tonight show like jimmy fallon
his hero he wants to do a tonight show
and interview like tana mojo or people
like that about
their day how's your day
and i i hope he's still able to do that
even though he murdered those people
i believe in second chances like christ
i went on a date the other day here in
texas with a gentleman who told me that
his
uh he was younger in his 20s because my
uh my when i told my parents i was gay
every story of these gay guys in texas
is like terrifying
when they came out um he said when i
told my parents i was gay they did it my
mother did an exorcism on me
we were eating crepes outside in a crepe
place and i was like horrified
and i went what he goes yeah but i
didn't care i was high as [ __ ]
i was like well that's still very
disturbing to hear he goes bats whatever
so like what did they so like literally
he's just high as [ __ ]
and his mother's like doing some crazy
exorcism on him
to get the gay out of him one kid
uh dude not kid let me be careful here
the [ __ ] you know
comedy police one gentleman was like
college age like a little older
was like um when i came out of the
closet
my father took me on a ride and told me
i was going to burn in hell
it was like so everybody has these crazy
stories
um it's wild and i remember that
because my parents did it in a very
different way
but it was as it was as
detrimental to me and and it was as
i i considered violent when i told him i
was gay my
my my i remember my father saying to me
there
there was a hundred dollars on the
mantle this afternoon it's not here now
so it's really minimizing what i was
going through and i said
i don't understand what that has to he
goes there was a hundred dollar bill
on the mantle for the cleaning lady
terry it's not there now it's gone
do you know anything about that i said i
don't i don't know anything about i
don't i don't know why we're even
discussing this
but it was a way to not acknowledge me
as a person
you understand it was a way to minimize
me to otherize me
to make me not feel like a human being
you know and that that to me i'll always
remember so i always tell the people
that i
i my father just brought up some crazy
non-sequitur like there's oh there's
money missing
what i don't know doesn't make any sense
to me
but it is kind of crazy when you when
you meet people that had these uh wild
experiences people have gone through
exorcisms and
we just saw rogan's new club that he's
opening in texas it's going to be
amazing
truly amazing it's going to be really
wild you know
and i was arguing with him about austin
real estate this morning
i was saying hey man it's a little bit
of a bubble to overvalued he's like no
it's not
you know we go back and forth like i get
it it is a cool place to live
but you know it's a little bit of a
bubble here i think i'm looking at
houses now
you walk in there's 10 houses 10 offers
on every house
two of the offers are algorithms they're
not even people
like an algorithm is offered to buy this
house i'm like oh good
it just gets uh but i get to uh talk to
a lot of real estate uh
professionals and what's great about
realtors
is that like ben was dealing with these
realtors who do rentals and stuff and
it's like
they're not even full-time realtors so
you're calling them
they're at their other job they're like
trying to get into real estate
it's like you're calling them going hey
we sent over all the documents they're
like bagging groceries
at a heb or whatever the store is here
and they're like yeah yeah good good
we're making it happen
uh they're not even realtors yet they're
they're in the process of becoming
real estate agents like they have a
license but they don't have any clients
and no money
so you're calling people that are just
doing something else they're like
nannying for a child and you're calling
them and you're like hey we're making
this happen right they're like
yeah yeah yeah and then like a child's
vomiting on them
and they have to then change the child
because that's their day job that's the
money they make
you know and then a lot of these
realtors seem
to have brain injuries uh
traumatic brain injuries many of the
women um they seem
to have autoimmune disorders
they're very sloth-like creatures uh
they kind of collapse into the couch
they stare at you
um uh
when ben comes in i always mention his
wife so they don't think we're gay so
they don't like
not sell the house to [ __ ] or jack it
up
good good idea if you want to come here
and be [ __ ] you're going to pay
you'll pay but i was like ben and his
wife moved here and then
when ben leaves the room i look at the
realtor and i go i still suck
so it throws her because that's a
negotiation strategy
but no i mean the realtor we spoke to
today was a lovely woman who's
you know probably was in a car accident
i mean this woman
she's she's very sweet
but the type of sweet that someone is
when they didn't get enough oxygen at
birth
you know what i mean where it's like
they're just kind of
now i may lose the house because of that
now but that's okay
comedy first comedy first but i hope to
get it i'm i'm really excited
it's not that expensive and it's it will
be uh
reasonable um
but i want to make sure that i can put
in a pool because i like to swim
and that is my exercise dan carney just
got an apartment at like this uh you
know where kids live these 24 and not
kids
real people live there too these places
were like
you have everything you need by the way
is there
is there anything worse than a human
being
who moves into an apartment complex and
says this they go you got everything you
need
okay
you got a whole foods as
a teacher well what do you need
you got everything you need what the
[ __ ] wrong with you
i need much more than that i need more
than a [ __ ] whole foods and a place
to get socks
there's a gym and a pool
and whole foods you have
everything you need
what about for your soul
this basic [ __ ] culture of erecting
these
[ __ ] like cheap wood
plastic crap apartment buildings
and then putting them next to a [ __ ]
tj maxx
so you can go in and buy underwear and
they're going you got everything you
need why would you leave
everything's here why would you leave
and meet
people and experience other things
everything that you ever needed is here
in the pod
and then carney talks about it goes my
unit
like he doesn't even say his apartment
he goes my
unit he goes the unit doesn't have
washington draw i'm like
you shut the [ __ ] up the unit
the you i am in the unit and then he
tells me because i'm facing the pool
which is much better than facing the
what are we doing here life should be
about more than this
life should be about more than that i
understand a creature comforts matter
i understand convenience matters i get
it
but using the phrase everything you need
makes you sound like a basic [ __ ]
nobody who just needs so little
that you can live on the side of a
highway and have
socks and [ __ ] peanut butter and
that's
everything you need what are you talking
about
i need culture i need
people to fake their own death i need
people that go to bars
instead of spending time with their
family i need tragedy
i need people reliving traumatic
experiences from their youth
i need people that were in cults that
are
trying to get out of them or getting
into other ones
i need people that have brain injuries
trying to sell me houses
i need things i need more than an
apartment complex which is
[ __ ] 20 30 something staring at each
other
he goes i made a friend there he's a
music manager
my unit endless he's a good kid and i'm
happy he
has an apartment but this whole thing
this whole thing of like let's make life
into this boring [ __ ]
this hyper-consumerist horseshit where
is the
old woman who knows the secrets of the
universe
because she was kept in a cage for the
majority of her life
and she realizes that she was because
people loved her
she was angry at them for time but now
she realizes that they
were trying to keep her safe where's
that woman
where are the people who've come out of
jail and realized that jail is the only
fair place left in this country
where are they they're not in your unit
are they at the pool where are the
characters
the people that have the courage to say
that donald trump was too liberal
where are they oh do they provide you a
free continental breakfast
do you get free sure we went and looked
at a at a unit in l.a
steve steve bings and that was a basic
[ __ ] building too but for rich people
but i only considered living there
because i thought i might get the unit
where steve bing
flung himself out of the window because
i wanted to kill myself
from the same unit and because
just the idea of the person the in-house
sales team
having to show the unit again and going
[Music]
i mean we we don't even go into this but
steve bing and then also tim dillon
killed himself from this exact window
that's funny to me because then it's a
cursed apartment and then i have a
legacy
but these basic [ __ ]
little [ __ ] you know
complexes he's like you got to come see
my spot man it's pretty cool
oh is it is it pretty cool we can go
walk around whole foods and get bananas
oh is it cool wait me you and the music
manager hang out and get bananas
at the whole foods cause just everything
you need
well i need a little bit more
i need more
than that i'm just saying
everywhere i've lived there's been a uh
a lot of characters and i look at these
new apartment complexes and they're
devoid
of any character anybody that's really
going to say something
cool yeah you know what i mean like
but i'm i'm happy for him and i'm happy
that there are people out there that are
you know he's doing good he's opening
for me he has a nice apartment it's good
i just i i have to live in a place where
people have traumatic brain injuries
i have to live in a place where people
invent autoimmune disorders they do not
have
and medicate themselves for them i
that's just my rule
i have to live around glazed eyes
middle-aged women
who claim to have lupus and do not
that is where i must be i must not be
in um the little kearney complex
that's okay coming up on the program we
have uh katie
herzog and jesse's single
signal s who cares they're nerds
anyway they're trying to [ __ ] with them
because uh
i don't know what happened uh they they
write about
well katie's been massively canceled
katie katie's very
funny but everybody hates her because
she's the only lesbian left in america
and people don't like that
they don't like that and i'm not a huge
fan of it either after my experience
with those two gals in the desert
but katie they write they they said that
this guy jessie's harassing trans women
which he's not there's no proof of that
right he see i mean he just
wrote like maybe you know maybe a
seven-year-old shouldn't have you know
gender-reconstructive surgery and
everybody went hey you're a nazi and you
know how it goes
they don't like any of these people
whether it's andrew sullivan or
greenwald or anything
but i think katie herzog's really funny
and you like kitty herzog i love katie
and and what's funny is the side by side
of you and katie there's no difference
so yeah so we have them on and we have a
little bit of fun with them and we talk
about sub stack which is like a patreon
for writers
um and uh for those uh members of the
patreon we owe you a raw child episode
that's our higher tier the rothschilds
we're doing a two-hour video episode
we're gonna put it out which will
include
uh last month and this month every all
the other patreon members you shouldn't
be angry with us because we gave you an
extra episode
we did an extra thing for you and listen
to this i'm announcing this
nobody knows this ben is coming down to
omaha nebraska and we are doing a
special
uh i think we're going to try to do it
maybe outside the franklin credit union
oh wow the building that you from the
franklin scandal if you're a fan of the
show for a long time
you know that uh the uh who took johnny
documentary
and the franklin scandal uh you know
that me and ray comp covered
because we're journalists uh we're going
to go down oh my brisk and i i want to
go
see all of the different places where
uh from that scandal like visit the
credit union we're going to look
i mean we might even try to get i don't
know that we're going to do it because
now i'm going to say it and cia's going
to kill us
but harold anderson who's the publisher
of the omaha world herald which is a cia
magazine uh the newspaper and they just
you know
uh he had this barn where they were
supposed to be sacrificing
kids i mean it's really crazy but i
don't know if we'll be able to get near
that
but maybe should we put out there a
thing like if it
because we're gonna get so many trolls
but should we're gonna get so many
trolls
so many trolls if i make this
announcement
but should we put out there a thing like
if you know anything about the franklin
scandal and you're in omaha
should we interview you yeah i guess but
we're it's gonna be hard
it's gonna be hard to sift through i
mean
the emails i get i mean it's like
yeah yeah it's gonna be maybe we'll put
the kibosh on that
maybe we don't want that maybe we
actually do not want that
maybe we'll just do it ourselves maybe
we'll drive to iowa and try to get
noreen gosh but i mean
she's i have a lot of respect for her
but she you know she's played her tune
on this show before
i just don't know what what is there
anything new could be some updates
it's a bit of cold case since like 73.
yeah
how many updates are gonna be or 83
whatever it was update on johnny maybe i
don't know
if johnny gosh is alive right now and
doing stand-up comedy he should be going
back to being raped
how about that can i go on record and
say that
if johnny gosh is doing a one-man show
right now he should go back into the
cage
no but i think he's alive and if he is
alive does he watch the program
of course he does why wouldn't he that's
the other thing
you can't you live in one of these uh
complexes with these young professionals
you bring up mk ultra everyone looks
like you like they don't know what it is
who wants to live in that environment
you bring them back to they go what is
that uh
is that like a song by a mortal
technique perhaps
it might be but it's something else as
well
um oh you said two hour by the way it's
three hours that we
we gotta do for the ross you're getting
through why we haven't missed
i i think they're claiming that we
missed december is that
true i don't know because we there's a
reason we did a four half hour thing in
in in december
who is we already told them three we
told you young
is he leading these people oh the young
he's a great cartoonist i saw him
he's i believe leading some type of
insurrection he's leading a capital riot
of the rothschilds and telling us we owe
them all this stuff
let's negotiate young don come to the
table
and let's negotiate stop riling
everybody up young don
you're a sauce god we have respect for
you but come to the table and negotiate
what do we owe these people nine hours
of content i thought we were doing
episodes for them
what happened it was a crazy three
months i mean we moved who's saying
stop with the excuses no one cares who's
saying we missed the episode
the some of the raw child people is it
the sauce god
the sauce god has claimed we we owe
three hours yes
i mean this is a real problem this young
time
who is this guy get him up you're
talking about uh this guy
let me see if i can find him dom
is it the sauce god is that his name
something
yeah yeah this guy this guy young don is
he a cartoon or is he a person
he he makes cartoons about his life i
watch some of them there no they're
amazing he's very talented
but he's leading us some type of uh
insurrection on the patreon
of the royal child here the higher tier
we'll give them
sauce god call off the dogs we'll give
you your [ __ ] content
this is him where is he skiing all the
time
this guy what is he just skiing i guess
so
let's see let's get the photos of him
skiing these right here
i've never skied in my life
keep going down
he's a pretty cool guy he's the most
yeah he's a very cool dude very cool
he's very cool he's probably the coolest
fan of the show that we have
although future is also a fan he's like
jacked
that's not jacked you don't know what
jacked is it's a six-pack if i took my
shirt off i'm i look exactly like that
but
i'm more defined oh enough young dom
please really showing off here oh god we
get it
is that you're upset that i don't have a
raw child episode while you're doing
that
you're upset you can't hear my voice
while you're [ __ ] doing push-ups
in the middle of venice beach wherever
the hell are you doing all right
we got to do this rock child for these
people because this guy's
going to kill us with his [ __ ] abs
this guy is the best-looking cartoonist
i've ever seen most cartoonists when i
had a meeting in nickelodeon it's all
pound pedophiles in there it's
pedophiles whose dicks don't even work
in nickelodeon
they're just they're only sexual
attractions to cereal
um so we're gonna do the two and a half
hour
rothschild we're gonna do that so
everybody relax there we're gonna be
fine
and i wanted to close by saying this
before i do the interview i
support david dobrik
i think he was wrong he shot those
people but
he's always seemed to me like a guy that
will make it right
i don't like to pile on the piling on
you know of what's happening people just
pile onto him a lot of people piled on
a lot of people and all he did
was make his friend make out with a dude
and i maybe film a woman being raped
now that does sound quite bad
but i don't know if he did any of that
all i know is that he shot six asian
people
and two whites and in response to that
he's lost
the the partnership with dollar shave
club
you're more than welcome on the david
david
if you think things are bad now and you
want them to get worse
we're always here for you for any of you
anybody who's in this cancellation storm
and you want to come on here and talk
about
why the royal family killed princess
diana
this is the venue for you come on in
no problem it's not a big deal
i'm sure it'll work out fine i gotta go
perform now
some of these audiences in austin have
been great some of them are soft
some of these austin city comedy
audiences have been soft
suburbs are great cap city was in the
suburbs they're great you draw from
people drive 45 minutes an hour to get
there
great some of these austin audiences are
just cool people
you know women with full sleeve tattoos
you know
to me it's hey i don't want that
i'm a suburbs boy unless i'm in new york
city i'm a suburbs kid
so uh i just you know some of these
audiences have been soft and it's been a
little
it's been a little disappointing for me
but ben and his wife came to no shows
which i appreciate
that was very sweet of you oh can we
come to one tonight though oh
i asked you if we could get tickets but
you're all sold out i'm sure we could
shove you somewhere
we'll see perhaps we'll see maybe you
come to the late show tonight yeah cause
i got to edit this thing yes
maybe i'll i'll text you there's no
pressure it's
you know again these audiences some of
them have been great last night late
show was great
early show was okay thursday was like
and they're all having a good time it's
just there's 350 people in the sea
in a theater that seats 1200. uh it's
they've taken out all the people so that
uh we've killed the energy of the show
and also it doesn't
help at all against covet so that's very
important to me is that we have both of
those things
happening at once but um
without further ado she's the last
lesbian in the united states of america
he is being accused of harassing and
waging a campaign
to harass trans women uh and they both
deny those things please welcome uh
katie herzog
and whatever his name is who cares
we'll do a quick ad break and then the
bluetooth unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in a chewable
format at a fraction of the cost
bluetooth tablets help men achieve
harder stronger erections to combat all
forms of ed erectile dysfunction
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discrete package
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com
consult with one of the licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days
the best part is well done online
bluetooth licensed medical
providers work with you to find the
right ingredient and strength for your
prescription don't like swallowing pills
no problem here
bluetooth dinner falls
tablets are chewable you like tablets
made in the usa and they prepared ship
direct
with their two main ingredients blah
blah blah
blip so it's cheaper than a pharmacy go
to bluechew.com
promo code td to receive your first
month free we thank bluetooth for
sponsoring the podcast
keeps you losing your hair you got to
keep the hair that you have if you're
ready to take action prevent hair loss
go to keeps.com
tim dillon two out of three men are
going to experience some form of hair
loss by the time they're 35 this is true
more than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness there
are only two
fda approved medications that can
prevent hair loss keeps offers both
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home
low cost discreet packaging these
treatments start at 10 bucks
wow keebs has more five-star reviews
than any of its competitors prevention
is key
treatments could take four to six months
to see results so act fast
keeps dot com slash tim dillon that's
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dylan it's a great way
to keep your hair on your head and
support this podcast
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show joined here by the co-host
of the blocked and reported podcast
katie herzog america's last lesbian the
final one
uh and jesse signal i believe i'm
pronouncing that right uh
single single but that's okay single
they are call them whatever you want
yeah it doesn't matter i i can i've
read on twitter i'm allowed to um tell
us what's going on
jesse you take the lead on this because
this does seem to deal with you
sub stack is like a patreon for writers
for people whose fan bases can
fund their journalistic endeavors and
there's a lot of people
that are angry with you that you are
being platformed by
sub stack and they're throwing out all
of these accusations
that you are harassing and stalking
trans
journalists but those accusations don't
seem to be substantiated by
any facts or data that anyone has
presented and yet everyone goes we have
the receipts
but we haven't really seen any receipts
yeah so this uh this stuff goes back a
few years katie and i met because we
both wrote articles about d
transitioners you know that's people who
transition their gender
and decide to transition back if you
write about that issue in the wrong way
and you're a liberal which we both are
people are going to really go after you
so
you know in katie's case they literally
okay they like burn stacks of the paper
when you wrote that right
yeah they burn sex the paper they put up
uh stickers around seattle with a
picture of my face calling me a nazi
sympathizer
which she is that's a separate issue
that has nothing to do with this um
yeah but in my case
i think it's like they go at you
differently if you're male or female
in my case these weird sort of sock
puppet accounts started popping up
on twitter suggesting uh like trying to
contrive some sort of me too incident
um you know everything from allegations
of dick pics ending
even though i've never sent a dick pic
because i know no one wanted no one my
girlfriend doesn't want to see my dick
i'm not sending anyone and you don't
have one
and i don't have one um yeah to her you
know accusations that i sent harassing
dms
this was mostly random people on twitter
and i ignored it because i
while this [ __ ] is going on i'm a
professional journalist i'm writing a
book i'm trying to do my job
it got escalated when some bigger name
writers one named nicole cliff who
writes for slade another name
jude doyle who's um like a well-known
feminist writer they just sort of
you know blasted to their platforms that
um that this stuff is true and the most
recent thing that happened was
people are mad that i'm on sub stack and
i'm doing pretty well on there although
i'm not one of the superstars so jude
doyle wrote a piece saying that i am
well known for stalking trans women that
was the exact term that was used
stalking
um and then another another person named
brianna wu did a tweet saying
uh this was great and katie helped me
out with this she said what was it
phrasing kid it was basically like i
have the receipts i know this stuff is
true
but i'm not going to say what the
receipts are i'm not going to say it and
katie quickly got some people to offer
i think we're up to 60 000 now uh if
brianna wu can
can show the receipts that i had done
any of this so
you know it's just been an example of
how if you're a journalist and you write
about certain issues in the wrong way
people
will really go after you and i think
social media
makes it easier to napalm someone's
reputation than it was
15 years ago it does seem to be an
escalation
from uh this person is problematic or
this person shouldn't be
able to write uh to this person is a
monster this person is a stalker this
person is a harasser this does seem to
be
kind of an escalation of what we've
previously seen where they just go this
person shouldn't have a platform
uh these accusations uh
seem to be um
an attempt to paint you as
a criminal yeah i mean it's like no
stockings
literally yeah it's a crime it's more
than just like
hey this guy has the wrong opinions it's
this guy's dangerous
he's following you home at night if he
disagrees with you
and he not only should he not have a
platform um
how do you combat this do you call a
lawyer what do you do
you know that's the extreme end of stuff
you can do
i i don't think anyone would begrudge me
doing that at this point
i'd like to avoid that so what i
basically do is i'll just to the extent
possible i'll fight back online i did
one sub stack post just
showing how over the years all these
weirdos have spread these rumors
i did another one um i think people are
starting to get it a guy named john k at
coolett just did a whole long article
just compiling
all this crazy stuff that's been going
on for years and
i've gotten a big wave of support you
know it's just
the whole point of this is to like so
doubt in your mind
so the next time a piece of mine is
rejected because i still want to write
for mainstream outlets or the next time
i don't get
you know journalists get fellowships or
whatever you'll never know if you're
getting rejected because
your application sucked which maybe it
would or because of these [ __ ]
rumors and i think
that's what it's designed to do it's
designed to punish you for writing
something you're not supposed to write
about
i love this idea that jessie is like is
stalking these women because he has some
sort of sexual
obsession with them when if you know
jesse his version of stalking someone
would be to walk up behind them and tell
her why she is wrong
there wouldn't be anything sexual about
it right it would just be
it would just be a pedantic you got this
study wrong this yeah
tapping women on the subway being like i
think you're doing feminism wrong stuff
like that yeah yeah
normal stuff yeah what now katie herzog
katie has been her staunch defender of
you uh which is katie's a real
she's a real uh you know i mean she's
got nothing to lose that's the other
thing
it's like it's not exactly notifications
yeah
katie's reputation i mean katie's
reputation is like i mean jesus
but uh we love katie because she's very
funny and jude doyle used to be on the
comedy beat by the way thank she's off
that
he's off that sorry jude doyle is off
the comedy beat now
which is good because he used to write
articles about
like jokes he didn't like but now he's
bothering you which i am
in full support of to be honest doesn't
affect me as much
what about because we i'm and i've
talked about this on the show i get
bored of the trans stuff
it's very boring to me a lot of trans
people kind of are nerds
a little bit not always but a lot of
them are products of online culture
which i kind of loathe
and not trans people but online culture
um
even though i have to function within it
um but i understand that this is a
topic right and i understand that this
is important i understand that
uh why in your estimation
what is the bigger play here i mean it
doesn't seem to be simply about people
transitioning or living their lives
openly there seems to be a political
uh architecture that all these issues
fit into like
there there seems to be more going on
why is this
happening you know i watched a little
bit of what you did with greenwald katie
about how sexual identity
has been expanded uh the lgbtq identity
has been expanded obviously trans people
always a part of that
but why is this happening now
and where does it lead so
this is a question that comes up a lot
and my theory
about why trans issues have taken up so
much space
uh within the cultural conversation
right now is because of the success of
gay marriage
so in 2015 after the supreme court
legalized gay marriage
all this infrastructure existed to
support this one cause there was
ma there were organizations and media
outlets all over
the country that were really dedicated
to fighting for for same-sex marriage
and after that was legalized in 2015
those organizations pivoted
and they didn't they didn't say like you
know we won we can just like shut the
whole thing down now they said like all
right we're gonna pivot to the next
issue and the next issue for them was
trans rights
and you can see this and somebody sent
me yesterday a graph
of uh of of of words like gay lesbian
bisexual and trans
tracked over time with the with glad
which is the gay and lesbian
something it's a group that tracks like
um anti-anti-defamation or something
what they track is like media coverage
of queer issues
and if you if you look over time you
know 10 years ago
most of their activism had to do with
gays and lesbians and you can see that
in just the language that they use in
their
documents and over time it's really
flipped so it used to be
trans issues were a small part of this
and gay issues were a big part of it and
now
if you look at these at these graphs
trans issues are a huge part of what
they talk about and gay and lesbian
rights are a small part of what they
talk about in part because of the
success of this
this one major issue um and at the same
time the media has sort of followed suit
um so so this issue that really affects
a very small percentage of the
population has
has really taken on uh sort of an
outsized role
in this like ongoing insane culture
where we're in the midst of right now
the
the one thing katie mentioned that i
want to emphasize is like the difference
between the [ __ ] you see online
and then what the average trans person
you you're friends with or email with
sure that that's what drives me crazy is
because they create like all
people email me and they'll say trans
activism is crazy it's like
the [ __ ] you see on twitter is crazy
like the average trans person wants to
be left alone and to have access to
hormones if they want hormones and for
you know if you're a member of a group
where for decades people denied you
the health care you wanted or they
kicked you out of your job or your house
you can understand how people get
defensive about that and none of that is
stuff where katie and i have any issue
it's just like
like you're saying this weird
concentration of media and twitter
[ __ ] just turns these
issues into just like [ __ ] cesspools
and i don't think that actually helps
anyone because
this isn't time any of us are spending
like talking about actual discrimination
or people getting kicked out of their
houses it's all just um
it gets really insane and detached from
the actual issues people have i also
think there's there's something about a
generation of people that have been
digitally native
meaning that they've their formative
experiences are primarily online they
their relationships are primarily online
they're heavily influenced by what's
going on online
uh the way that you get friends online
or the way that you are able to get
clout or whatever word you want to use
is by being a member of a group or being
in
kind of an insular bubble and that would
be very different if your experiences
were in the real world where you were
just
you know encountering vastly different
uh people
all the time whereas online you can kind
of draw a line uh draw a circle around
yourself and you go i'm a part of this
group or i'm a part of that group
and that's the way you have um you know
social interactions online that's the
primary way you do it is by
you know declaring yourself some i am
this thing
um and i know that abigail schreier went
on my friend joe rogan's podcast and
there was a big uh
to do about her you know kind of
basically saying hey
there's a lot of people here that are
not experiencing
genuine gender dysphoria that this is
some other psychological thing
happening and just by positing that just
by saying that that's a possibility
um you know it was a major he got a lot
of heat for having her on um
you know why is there such a resistance
to that why if i was a trans person
i would not want a lot of other
i don't want people pretending to be gay
there are men on stage
who claim to be bisexual they are not
they hook up with women they don't suck
dick
yet they know in this climate by saying
i've had bi
thoughts it endears them to a section of
the audience but it's like not i
am always a believer in being a real
[ __ ] you know like
i i was in florida i was i was [ __ ] a
guy in a pink hotel and i spent
four days complaining about the food and
speaking to management
that is a real [ __ ] if you are not
going to be that you're a waste of
my time so if i was a trans person
i would want only real
genuine people that were trans in the
thing i'd be like i don't why is there
such a
why do we want like i'm a comedian i
only want real comics
being comedians i don't want a corporate
strategist who
impersonates trump or whatever like i
don't need that it doesn't i don't
begrudge them their success but when we
talk about comedy and making people
laugh
i kind of want people that are actually
comedians
why is there such a like a open door
policy on like hey anybody come on in
well you you can't question anybody's
identity in this uh
in this era it becomes incredibly
problematic um
and it's really easy to fake some of
these things like
people probably aren't going to fake
their actual attraction like you might
say that you're queer because it's such
an ambiguous term
um you're probably if you're fake gay
you're probably not gonna like actually
get into a relationship with a man and
settle down and buy a [ __ ] miata with
them or whatever but these
terms like queer and non-binary are so
ambiguous
that anybody can sort of adopt these
terms you don't actually have to change
your behavior
um and you get you get oppression points
and
people get mad when you say this but
like you can see from
the rash of people who have been busted
recently
um you know posing as a member of a
different race
so there have been these academics
primarily academics for some reason
who you know are white people who have
who have
created these identities for themselves
rooted in some sort of race that they're
not actually a part of
if people are willing to do that like
that's hard to fake you gotta perm your
hair
you gotta tan you gotta get hoop
earrings or whatever
that's hard to do if you if you wanna
fake being queer non-binary all you have
to say is i'm queer non-binary
and you do get this sort of you know
people congratulate you you feel like
you're a part of something that's
probably a big part of it is that people
feel isolated from rural communities
but there's this weird element because
like uh you're a lesbian
uh you're gay tim i'm jewish although
not religious if someone questioned me
and said you're not really jewish i'd be
like
okay [ __ ] you because i'm an adult with
a stable sense of self i
i think there's this thing especially
made with younger people where like
their identities are so fragile and you
know people will literally at this point
put their
mental illnesses in their twitter bio
and people so want to sort of be
original and unique but in this very
pack play by numbers way and i just wish
people i don't know i'm trying to figure
out what's causing this i like to look
at things psychologically and i do think
people have a very fragile sense of self
and their only really validation is from
strangers on the internet which is a
very
unhealthy way to be if anyone says
you're not jewish just tell them you
go i look like a character from the
prince of egypt like i literally
what are you talking about like i look
like every
you look like the meme a little bit the
happy merchant a little bit like
the idea that you're not jewish is
absurd
but he's italian he's actually italian
posing yeah i could be there
is it that this online culture has kind
of flattened everybody where you know i
talk about this all the time you meet
people under a certain age
um they're weird in person
they're more comfortable online they uh
they don't make eye contact they don't
really know how to speak to people
at a dinner they can't function um
a lot of these people i feel like a lot
of their experiences are very uniform
because online culture
even though there are these diverse
bubbles everyone's talking about the
same things they're all in the same apps
it's
similar algorithms do you think that
people
are are just becoming dull and
boring and drones and their the lack of
real community and the lack of real
identifiable traits and characteristics
i don't talk about being gay a lot my
act it's not interesting everybody knows
that i am but
to me it's not interesting it's not 1987
i'm not dying of aids on a floor
although i'm sure people would love that
i just um i gravitate towards what i
think is funny or interesting
i've never viewed someone who you [ __ ]
mattering like i know that it's mattered
and people have suffered horrible
discrimination for it but
i don't understand why we now believe
that that's what makes you an individual
is who you have sex with or
what gender you identify as to me it's
just the least interesting thing about
anybody i want to know
if you've run an insurance scam or have
you ever considered faking your own
death i want to know
you know what your parents did for a
living and if you had an uncle that
found gold and a fjord in norway like
i don't know why we're just talking
constantly about these
really meaningless distinctions yeah but
in a lot of progressive communities like
the
trajectory has been the exact opposite
like you're a you're supposed to talk
about identity your identity all the
time
b if you experience any adversity even
online [ __ ]
you're supposed to act like you've been
harmed horribly so
you know once in a while some dumb
teenager in like ohio will send me an
auschwitz meme or whatever it happens
if you're jewish online it happens to
you the idea that i'm going to give that
kid
which one is it the one with the i'm
kidding keep going
was that youtube holy [ __ ] uh but the
idea that i'm gonna give that kid power
some like [ __ ] up 17 year old power by
be like
oh my god this is a hate crime what am i
going to do especially when
you know it's like with gay people and
aids in the 80s there was
actual horrific anti-semitism having
some idiot
tweet a meme at you on twitter is not
it's not it's nothing in the grand
scheme of history i don't understand
there's something about media culture
and academic culture right now
where it's gotten the point where people
will literally fake being black or
biracial so they can
it's so weird especially given how much
actual oppression there is in the world
that oppression just
doesn't really take place on twitter
what about it
yeah it just it comes down to like
tribalism
and you know sort of team sports and
turning and turning everything into in
in our culture entities um into teams
like jesse said like someone can send
him an auschwitz meme and sometimes i
get auschwitz means because people think
because of my last name that i'm jewish
it's very flattering
um you know or or say that he's a you
know say that he's a stalker
and somehow it is more harmful for
someone like jesse
to push back on the rumor that he's a
stalker the defamation that he's a
stalker
um and he'll get accused of harassing
people for responding to these
to these [ __ ] claims whereas the act
of calling someone a stalker is not
somehow enough to get you run out of
media lucy nicotine is a company founded
by caltech scientists and former smokers
looking for better and cleaner nicotine
alternative
i've never smoked and have no addiction
problems but for some of you that do
you want to get the cigs out of your
mouth so they have three cool flavors
winter green cinnamon pomegranate
they're gum it's a lozenge you chew it
you suck it
each and every flavor tastes great it's
convenient and discreet they can be
enjoyed anywhere on flights at work or
on the go
even in the gym call to action
oh sorry i'm not supposed to say that
it's 20 21 get rid of your cigarettes
unplug your vape
throw out your dip and get some loosey
nicotine gum lodges
it's 20 21 get rid of your cigarettes
throw out your vape and the dip get some
lucy nicotine gum or lozenges this is
the real deal a subscription to lucy
comes directly to your door each month
it's so simple and you don't have to
leave your house
because lucy has delivery down the
timberland show listeners go to lucy.co
use promo code tim
to get 20 of all products on your first
order including gamma lozenges
that's lucy.co use promo code tim at
checkout lucy.co promo code tim
at checkout also i have to give this
disc
sorry leave that in also
i have to give this disclaimer warning
this product contains nicotine derived
from tobacco nicotine is an addictive
chemical
magic spoon is a cereal it's great it's
keto it's
neato it's got zero grams of sugar 13 14
grams of protein
400 grams of carbs in each serving it's
keto friendly gluten free grain free soy
free low carb gmo free we've got
exciting news
magic spoon will be releasing two
amazing new flavors this month for a
limited time only we're talking about
cookies and cream and maple waffle
and if that isn't the most comforting
indulgent combination i don't know what
it is this is the ultimate treat
yourself combo
so make sure you get some while you can
for a limited time
build your own box we've got custom
bundles cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter and cinnamon if you're not
listening from canada magic spoon that
ship's there as well
or if you are listening from canada go
to magicspoon.com
tim dylan to grab the new limited
edition cookies and cream maple waffle
or a custom butter can we get some of
this [ __ ] for free
i can't get anything here and be sure to
use some of this promo code tim dillon
and check out save five dollars off your
order
this offer is now good anywhere in the
us or canada but only when you use our
code at checkout and magic spoon is so
confident
in their products it's back with 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
what about this alliance which i find
hilarious between like these
mega corporations and woke culture this
seems to be like
the big dominant theme in in in you know
capitalist america right now is that
like
you have these uh companies like nike
that have literally slave labor
camps and china producing uh their the
shoes they sell
but they also are doing as much as they
can vocally to support all of these
different movements
it's very funny you know the woke
corporate ceos hilarious to me
um other than it just being you know
kind of buffoonish and cartoonish
um it does seem to be a real danger
because you you have basically these
corporations that are like listen we
want to continue
with unfair labor practices paying
people low wages
we don't want to give anyone health care
we want to continually
[ __ ] on the middle class in this country
we don't mind
um you know making billions and billions
of dollars essentially on the backs of
people who are not paying fairly
as long as we engage in this
performative activism and come down on
the right side
is this this weird unholy alliance
between
big business uh and and these
profit-driven enterprises
and this kind of you know virulent
strain of world culture
and does it enable those companies to
kind of continue doing what they're
doing and escape
a lot of criticism i mean i i think so
if i was someone who called myself a
leftist radical and my rhetoric was
completely indistinguishable from like
raytheon and halliburton's diversity
statements i would i would ask certain
questions about that
a lot of this [ __ ] is just symbolic man
i mean if you focus all day on this
stuff or like putting it just
i watched an episode of madman they put
a disclaimer about how a guy was gonna
have blackface when anyone who watches
this episode knows the whole point is
this guy's an [ __ ] why is he in
blackface
these are symbolic moves that don't
really challenge power
in in any way and i i don't know there's
an
everyone uses the term performative but
that's what it is do you think any of
these companies would actually
raise wages in a meaningful way or
improve their labor practices or not
you know employ slave labor in china
it's all it gets exhausting really
quickly i feel like
right you see the same thing in
education so you have these you know
private schools particularly private
high schools in places like l.a and new
york where they're going through this
very performative sort of diversity
trainings um
where you know teachers or students or
whoever are encouraged to sort of
confess their whiteness
when if if these schools actually this
is something caitlyn flanagan pointed
out in the atlantic
these schools are mostly untaxed so if
you know they're sitting on
billion-dollar endowments and if they
actually wanted to do something to
address
inequalities or inequities in education
what they would do is
is is you know fight for for to revoke
their own uh
non-profit tax status or tax exemption
or they would give away their [ __ ]
endowment to the shitty public school
down the street but instead what they do
is like build another waterfall or a
theme park on their campus and then
bring in a diversity trainer
it's all it's it's just performance
yeah it's it's it's wild to watch i
don't know where it
uh where it ends it's uh i tend to think
we all have five to seven years to make
money in the world out of here so
save your money no i mean i'm dead
serious about that and i've said this
before
i believe um and this is not any i don't
want to be right
about this i believe that if things kind
of keep going the way they're going
there's a small window of time that
people are going to have
to build fan bases online and then that
too will be extinguished do you think
i'm being too dramatic the thing
you should have been kicked off of
patreon probably yeah 17 episodes ago
but they're not going to kick you off
because you're bringing in too much
money yeah
i think maybe do you listen to the
patreon episodes
i don't i don't listen to those i should
i mean they're very funny i think
patreon shows that are big like chapo
and kumtown and myself we're all wild
and we're all
funny and we're all comics and obviously
chapo is more political but like
there doesn't i don't know there's no
nobody's engaging like hate speech or
whatever i'm not rallying anyone to a
cause
you did you did threaten to to bomb
those lesbian subaru those
lesbians are those they deserved it
they are crafty and you gotta watch them
um
and i'm gonna i'm gonna tell them about
this at the next meetup yeah
well there's only nine of you left
that's that article you posted so i'm
sure you all know each other there's
nine lesbians left
every now and then katie will go dark
for a few days and then she'll just pop
her head out with like
there are nine lesbians left and we and
i were
fighting for and you said there's no
lesbian bars right
isn't that your pet cause now uh
not not neutering animals and more
dyke bars i believe that's the beat
you're on now
yeah that's it how did you two meet i
mean obviously you wrote the articles
and then everybody
everyone hates you both but how did you
guys become afraid you seem to have like
a real friendship it's kind of like
heartwarming
it's it's it's like a patreon friendship
really
it's more of a i think of jessie as my
pod bottom
situation no katie's my uh kitty's my
rodl my ride or die lesbian
now do people like andrew sullivan who
doesn't return emails i don't know who
he thinks he is
guys out of his mind but who are the
kings of sub stack you have greenwald
who are the big dogs on sub stack
glenn greenwald this historian of all
person who's really good heather
cox richardson who are the other ones uh
uh yoshimoto sullivan
andrew sullivan yeah oh man iglesias is
huge yeah
a bunch of cis white men and what are
they all making
money millions more than five hundred
thousand the
best more than uh more than a million do
you think a few of them multiply
well in the case of andrew yeah yeah
yeah
if he's if he's i don't think he's even
number one but that's what's so
that's what's so weird about this is
like there's there's massive demand
for these opinions and these are bigoted
reactionary opinions and yet
these guys don't really have a place at
like mainstream outlets and then the
mainstream outlets wonder why they're
losing credibility it's a weird process
to watch this unfold
well the great thing about this is so
after there's been this
insane like sub stack war over the past
week where subsequent so so for your
audience who doesn't know sub sac is
a newsletter platform so it's basically
a bunch of independent writers who
you cultivate your own list and then
they can give you money and you can make
a [ __ ] ton of money if you if you've got
a big list
and so there's been all of these people
threatening to leave sub stack
because of people like jessie and glenn
greenwald and andrew sullivan and me to
a lesser degree
but the platform that they're talking
about going to is this platform called
ghost which is like a total free speech
platform
so i think what we do is that all of us
just need to migrate over to ghost and
they'll have to leave that one too we
can slowly de-platform these people
by just moving to whatever dude i'll
commit to this now if three or more of
the people who complained about my
presence on subtech i'll move to the
same platform i will start a newsletter
there
that they're paying advances to people
people are upset about that that they're
getting
i didn't get one but the really big
names they'll give them an advance and
then um
yeah it's just in advance then then they
take that out of their earnings so it's
it's the same
thing a book publisher does people are
treating this as like a weird
conspiratorial thing people are also
forgetting that sub stack
is a for-profit company it's very hard
to like pin down
what the exact complaint is so you'll
have someone with
1 20th of the experience and audience of
andrew sullivan
treating it as a scandal that subtech
wanted andrew sullivan to come on board
andrew sullivan now makes more than a
million dollars according to katie so
it's been weird cause i don't know he's
also a guy that like pioneered blogging
he's been in the game for decades he's
published multiple books like
there is there is a reason that you
would pay a guy like that in advance
right and the i don't think he even took
the advance because the advance
if you're if you're really big the
advance is i think at the high end 250
thousand dollars but if you can make a
million dollars a year on the platform
there's no reason to do it yeah
um so is this the future of journalism
do you think or is is that overstating
it to a degree
i hope not the problem is like i think
they'll always be
people that like me and you know katie
and i are both in our late 30s we've
been around a while we've built up
audience
we're lucky enough that we'll probably
always i think be able to make a living
just with our like
dumb opinions and katie's anti-semitism
and stuff the problem is
like actual journalism like who's
covering the cops who's covering city
hall
there's almost no money for that and
that's what i'm most worried about i'm
not worried about us i'm worried about
like [ __ ]
50 year old guys who built up a career
covering the police who's going to cover
the police in 10 years i i think no one
knows the answer to that so
i'm much more worried about that than
the people everyone's bitching about on
substance
that's a great question who's going to
do the like shoe leather actual
reporting on
institutions public institutions right
a bigger threat to journalism is not sub
stack it's
the same threat that has been
disseminated or decimating it for the
past 15 years which is
google and craigslist and facebook it's
the fact that
local papers have been hollowed out but
you don't see the people bitching about
some stacked platforming people like
jesse doing anything to
you know to help out the real crisis
which is the fact that
local papers are dying well i
i like both of you i wish both of you
the best of luck your show is called
blocked and reported it's
growing people really enjoy it people
like it
um you know and i mean i i urge all my
followers and fans to go check it out
it's a kind of refreshing uh you know
you have a good rapport both of you and
you both certainly
are i just we're just so bored of the
trance you know we're
we were in a very low profile war with
the weinstein brothers
and um you know the war that no one
asked for and no one wanted but i i've
declared war on the intellectual dark
web
and they've responded in kind and um
i've taken lex friedman from them i've
taken lex and uh and i and but
but uh i made a joke where i was like
the greatest minds of our time just talk
about trans stuff all the time and it's
like boring to me
i mean how about this like i get it i
would not give any kid hormones but it's
kind of like
hey if you transition and it doesn't
work out it's almost like you got a bad
tattoo
i'm kind of treating it now like hey man
you [ __ ] up
maybe there's got to be more of that in
society maybe we have to say you were a
stupid seven-year-old and sorry
you know and now you don't have a penis
and now you don't have a penis and i
don't know i just
it it sucks all the air out of the room
but i do understand why it's important
to talk about
did you see the head of drag queen story
hour got busted with a bunch of child
porn
what's going on over there you take this
one katie
just uh i guess you just like he was too
much of a cutie of a cuties fan i think
that's what
i'm telling you right now anyone who
wants to read to children is
automatically suspect drag queen or not
anyone who goes to a library voluntarily
to read dumb books to kids is so
stupid that anyone who has a child i
think falls into that category well
anyone who has a child is a pedophile
there's no other way
i i think that having children is
somewhat important because you need
uh you need to to raise a well-regulated
militia
that will guarantee the security of the
free state kim
you should become a sperm donor i think
i know some lesbians who uh mila and
jonah they live
do you know i'm literally asking do you
know them no i don't know
though i don't i did look them up on
instagram i did find them on instagram
they did a whole thing where they were
like we love
joe rogan and we'll let him spend time
in our home because he likes our
furniture or whatever
you know these are um i'm off airbnb i'm
literally the platform that cannot get
back on i've tried
um it's a complete and utter
uh you know campaign to destroy me and
uh but i will continue to fight i had no
idea that it would get
so contentious with these ladies and
they called me fat which is ableist why
are they on the platform i don't know
why they're allowed to be
on the platform it's odd to me that
they're able to be on the platform but
apparently there are different rules
tell everyone where they can find both
of you uh your show
and everything is there going to be like
a sub stack convention do you guys
do you guys like do like a big do you do
like a meet and greet with like you guys
and barry weiss and andrew sullivan like
just that
does that ever happen do you guys do
like uh meet and greet convention
mag khan but first it was actually was
it two years ago now we had a
happy hour for katie in brooklyn and
andrew sullivan was there it was a good
night
wow what a fun night the mean
andrea was drinking jager shots if i
remember correctly yeah
yeah uh yeah so i mean everyone check us
out please patreon.com
reported i'm at
jessesingle.substance.com if you want to
see why
all my horrible reactionary stuff that
uh they tried to de-platform me over
and then uh oh yeah i have a book coming
out totally separate subject but check
out the quick fix
it's out april 6 if you want to support
me and katie what's it about
it's about like sort of [ __ ] ted
talk psychology and why we keep
uh falling for it it's it's it's not
culture wary but i i think people will
like it and should uh
give it a google maybe katie herzog
where can
where can the people find you
they can't i'm in a bunker in western
washington i don't want them to find me
um i am on twitter at kitty pursehog
i have a sub stack newsletter called
moose nuggets which is
as as you mentioned is about canine
testicles the most pressing issue
um in america right now and what else
yeah check out the podcast that's pretty
much all i do
i'm uh i'm really more of a part-time
worker at this point yeah i mean katie
is very funny
ben ben thinks you're very funny my
producer very funny that was a very
funny email you said i think
yeah ben ben is like in love with you
well i think ben's very handsome so
maybe we can uh
thank you katie i believe i am the
looker on the show that is what i
that is what i believe because i am the
the show is me
so if people weren't looking at me they
wouldn't watch
katie herzegovina
[Laughter]
well you know i literally this is true
when i lived in california
i i was talking to this uh
uh this this this there was a high
school track
kid in my neighborhood who used to run
around and i was convinced
i know where we're going no it's just a
thin high school track kid
and i would always ask him about trans
issues and he had to tell me he wasn't
katie herzog
he was just a think he had to tell me
and i said katie i
had no idea you could afford to live in
this neighborhood let's be real
and uh but it apparently was not you
when i learned that the hard way
um but we do appreciate both of you
coming on we're fans and we hope that
you guys continue to
thrive good to talk to you thank you
guys